That’s the lemongrass.
Patricia Frank
It's still got the smell. When my kids were babies
we used to go out hunting, swimming. Hot day, fine.
Bush tucker. That was back in the ‘90s. And today you go out,
you can't even stand the heat. And that's it there.
In the ground, in the ground.
Melissa Rankine, Tennant Creek resident
Wupurarni people means Aboriginal people here in Warumungu.
That's how they survive with bush tucker, going out, getting bush tucker. Go out
hunting and doing all that stuff. But they can't do it anymore. Because it's too hot.
Patricia Frank
The animals are still, goanna mainly, they still hibernating because they can't
tell the season now, you know, because of the hot.
Melissa Rankine
And we know it’s called global warming,
we know it's climate change, and that's what's happening around the world.
And the bush plants and the bush tucker, they're all dying, and we can’t get them.